hey guys it is friday the tenth of june
and i'm here to get you caught up on all
the biggest things that happened in
gaming this week seda project red is
making a new witcher 3 patch which
should address all major reported issues
community manager marcin mullet
confirmed that it will address a problem
in the blood and wine expansion where
the camera fails to lock onto enemies
but there's no official word on whether
it will fix the reported issues related
to game freezing and missions failing to
load he confirmed that the developer
hope to have it out as soon as possible
this week EA announced fifa 17 and
confirmed that it will be powered by the
Frostbite engine fifa 17 will be the
first in the series to move on from the
ignite engine the Frostbite engine is
currently used in games like star wars
battlefront and need for speed for the
moment details on the game itself have
been vague but EA has said frost by
delivers authentic true to life action
takes players to new football worlds and
introduces fans two characters full
depth and emotion the full reveal is due
to take place during a is pre e3 event
ea play on jun 12 at 1pm PT fever 17 is
set to launch on ps4 xbox one 360 ps3
and pc in north america on sep tember 27
and globally on September 29 if you
don't want to have the bethesda
conference potentially spoiled for you
copy areas since you're a game a wreck
and they have a pretty good idea of
what's gonna happen the publication have
reported the discovery master could be
on the way for ps4 and xbox one
supposedly this will include all DLC
improved visuals and mods the report
added that pathetic also planning to
announce the evil within to Wolfenstein
Xin you order to and a completely
reworked version of prey to the latter
of which was previously leaked by
industry insider shinobi GTA fans have a
lot to be excited about this week as a
massive GTA online update has arrived
the update is called further adventures
in finance and felony and is one of the
biggest expansions to arrive so far it
lets you become the CEO of a criminal
enterprise by acquiring an executive
office and hiring a team of a
see it's the update adds in a line of
deluxe office suites to better suit your
burgeoning evildoer career the suites
include a full-time assistant helipad
boardroom arcade game and optional
storage space that lets you personalize
your gun loadout before you leave for
criminally the update also features a
bunch of new jobs and challenges as well
as the new adversary mode that caused
quite a bit of murdering as you'd expect
there will also be new vehicles attire
and weapon attachments for the full list
of everything that's in the update you
can check out our story on site finally
this week we've got our first official
look at watchdogs to watch dogs two
centers around Marcus Holloway who
belongs to hacker group dead sec it
takes place in San Francisco and unlike
the first game this one will feature a
fully hackable game world Holloway is a
bit more of a social butterfly compared
to watch dogs ones Aiden Pearce so
you'll be teaming up with other hackers
and you're able to play the entire game
in multiplayer if you so choose you'll
be able to park all your way around SF
use DIY 3d printed weapons and control
Bert a quadcopter Scout drone and a
remote control car to help you with your
hacking shenanigans and yes the driving
will apparently be less [ __ ] this time
around my words not ubisoft's watchdogs
two will be out on November 16 this week
on tonight you can check out the biggest
III things to look forward to on the
gist Lucy & Co wrap up the latest
happenings on Game of Thrones and we
give you the lowdown on the biggest III
rumors do let me know all of your
thoughts and feelings on this week's
stories and be sure to stay tuned to
gamespot next week for all our live
shows III coverage and news updates are
see again then
Oh
Oh